a los 8 años me vi obligado a entender
que todos pasamos por experiencias
difíciles en la vida unos más difíciles
que otras pero todos en algún punto
nosotros llegamos a sufrir para alguien
puede ser hice otro colegio y revivió
otro país creo que todos en algún punto
de nuestras vidas también sufrimos la
muerte de un ser querido y una vez que
la experiencia es para mí fue mi
secuestro un lunes 11 de enero yo
llegaba del colegio en mi bus escolar
me bajé entonces de la urbanización
cuando de repente mi guardia me llamó y
me dijo que tenía los papeles para mi
mamá me acerqué para ver qué era lo que
tenía cuando de repente bien salió para
atrás me tapó la boca los ojos y me
empujó hacia el baño de la casita el
guardia
ahí me revisó a veces que tenía un
teléfono y lo único que tenía era ni
mucho el escolar y como era tan chiquita
no tenía un teléfono y me dijo que las
farc ya tenía una familia y que me
estaba buscando a mi persona como rehén
yo era tan ingenua que ni siquiera lo
que las farc pero lo único que entendía
era que él estaba ahí para ayudarme y
para proteger a mi familia protegerme a
mí que estaba ahí por buena gente
me dijo que tenía que esconderme porque
me estaban buscando entonces que íbamos
a vuelos para que me pueda quedar ahí
hasta que se solucione el problema con
mi familia me cogió a mí y usaba pues mi
mochila me metí en un basurero me tapó
la boca y yo no veía esto pero sentí
cómo nos vimos en un auto después
algunos minutos abrió el basurero salí y
me di cuenta que no estamos acá si mis
abuelos estaba en un terreno baldío con
una quebrada a un lado y elige porque
quiero entiendo si supuestamente íbamos
donde mis abuelos porque estamos acá
dijo que ya habíamos ido donde mis
abuelos y que ya estaba ahí la gente
también las farc y que tenía que
esconder no saber qué podíamos hacer en
ese momento sacó un arma grande la cargó
y me dijo que yo no hacía caso lo que me
decía me iba a matar yo prefería no se
preguntó si ya muy confundida el mismo
tiempo es supuestamente estaba ahí
ayudando a mí entonces bajar la quebrada
y llegamos después de unos minutos de
bajar
un árbol grande donde estaba una mochila
apoyada en el árbol y otra vez me
confundí porque dije así es que
supuestamente no tenemos que estar aquí
porque entonces está como esta mochila
esperándonos
entonces prefiero preguntar porque tenía
miedo de que él decida agredirme de
alguna manera
me sentó en el piso puso una funda
grande de basura me sentó encima de la
funda y me amarró a los tobillos
alrededor del árbol mis piernas
abrazaban al árbol y mi esposo los
tobillos mejor tres latas de atún y mi
hijo ya regreso yo sólo tenía mi mochila
cuando él se fue y me di cuenta que por
primera vez estaba completamente sola
que yo no sabía cuánto tiempo iba a
estar ahí entonces que no podía comerme
toda la comida de una que tiene que
racionar mi comida
pero en preocupe es porque dije que
tengo comida pero no de tomar y dura más
tiempo sin comer qué síntomas y de besar
mi mochila y me di cuenta que justo ese
día sorprendentemente no me había tomado
un pequeño cartón de jugo que me había
llevado al recreo
y el jugo y por una vez dije guau nunca
me hubiera imaginado que algo tan
pequeño lograría tener tanto valor
y empezamos al primer día no podía
moverme no podía hacer nada quería
desesperarme al mismo tiempo sabía que
no podía no tenía cómo salir ahí tenía
que mantener la calma me acordaba que
cuando yo iba a la playa con mi familia
dormía y cuando yo me dormí el tiempo
pasaba más rápido en tu empecé a darme
vida intentado hacer muchas fiestas pero
no me di cuenta que cuando uno duerme
también sueña y por primera vez en mi
vida mis sueños de lo mejor que mi
realidad y cuando me despertaba a
destetar yo y mi pesadilla
y hubo un sueño que fue muy importante
para mí fue muy recurrente también que
era yo para de una vereda un tren y en
cada vagón del tren había un miembro de
mi familia y ese vagón no sólo contenía
ellos sino también que tenía su
personalidad su relación conmigo su
vínculo y yo veía como este tren se iba
y yo estaba parado un avión no puede
hacer nada no pueda subirme y todo el
mundo se fía de mí y era como una señal
de que todos están diciendo mí porque no
lo voy a volver a ver y no creo que ahí
fue cuando yo dije no va a ser así yo
voy a hacer esto por ellos y yo voy a
sobrevivir esto porque les voy a volver
a ver yo no voy a darme por vencida
empezó a pasar la primera noche después
digamos siguiente día empecé a comer una
lata todo el día porque no sabía cuánto
tiempo iba a estar ahí
hasta que llegamos al tercer día me
empieza a debilitarme ya me hacía falta
hidratación hacía falta comida y no creo
que esa noche fue la primera vez que
lloré porque sonámbula desperté cogí mi
juego y me lo acabe y dije ahora sí me
voy a morir porque ya no tengo una de
tomar
en ese momento me asusté mucho pero
también me convencía que no podía perder
la calma porque si es que yo me
desesperaba nivel logra nada más que
perder la poca fuerza que me sobraba
estudié regreso el secuestrador mesa con
las esposas del tobillo bajamos hacia el
río nos quedamos un rato ahí y me
acuerdo que yo la wta se elige gracias
gracias por cuidarme a mí para
protegerme por estar tanto ocupado por
en familia porque yo no tenía la
capacidad de entender que alguien podía
ser tan malo
cruzamos el río yo siempre tenía mi
mochila puesta porque una de mis
preocupaciones más grandes eran los
libros de la biblioteca no se pueden
perder porque me van a cobrar y mi papá
me va a matar
cruzamos el río él me vio empujando mío
apuntando también con su arma y me decía
que le tenía que ser todo lo que él me
pedía y tiene que serlo rápido entonces
vamos a un diferente del lugar después
de haber cruzado el río ahí pasamos una
noche y así siguieron progresando los
días
normalmente el pasado la noche conmigo y
se iba durante el día pero también
habían días en los que él no regresa de
las noches y me acuerdo que yo le pedí
de favor que no me dejes pasado aquí yo
no me vea y que por más de que hubiera
querido ir me hubiera querido escapar no
tenía como ya no tenía los fuerzas y
tampoco sabía dónde estábamos pero igual
cuando éste iba yo intentaba cortar mis
esposas con las tijeras que tenía mi
mochila y después de algunos intentos no
creo que por fin logré dañar las esposas
con él meza fobia no puedo poner y dije
por fin logré lo que quería pero no me
di cuenta que fue peor porque fue lo que
hizo que en vez de que él por fin me
crea de que yo no me va a escapar hizo
que después de unos días de seguir
moviéndonos del lugares
me acueste coge un tronco grande y dos
brazos y los menos de amarra este tronco
grande marco este y ahí si yo ya no
podía mover y en ese rato tenía todas
para desesperar me tiene a todos para
sufrir y ponerme a llorar y gritar pero
me tuve que convencer que mi mente
controlaba mi cuerpo que si yo era capaz
de mantener la calma aquí iba a poder
controlar mi cuerpo también y así fue
como pasé todo ese día que fue
probablemente uno de los peores momentos
del secuestro porque no tenía cómo
moverme en el absoluto si tal vez
amarrado un árbol tampoco pero tenía al
menos como rascarme la cara y hay que
con su peso subir un insecto enorme y
dije yo sé cómo se hace es que no me
muevo porque estoy acostada me muevo
porque me pica d'estats el insecto y no
tenía ni citar como sacármelo de encima
porque mis brazos estaban amarrados
después del regreso y luego cage le
rogué una vez más por favor ya no me
siga teniendo marrada que no me va a
escapar
y me creo que también me trajo una funda
de pan otro día me trajo un poco de
arroz pero no me traía nada es tomarlo
de vez en cuando un poco y se llama dos
minutos de lugares mediante losa del
tiempo y uno de esos días llegamos a una
cascada grande donde había agua empozada
abajo
y me acuerdo como yo quería tomar agua
es esperada mente porque me está
deshidratando pero me acordaba que yo
tomaba esa agua nivel tóxica lentes
decidí tomar un agua que llegaba a este
agua en posada pero eso está en
movimiento en todo un poco más limpia en
ese momento era mi instinto de
supervivencia que me hacía pensar de esa
manera tome un poco de esa agua
igualmente ok sí que esa noche vomité y
me acuerdo que ese comedor me gritó
mucho y casi me intentó matar porque
estaba tan bravo de que yo le había
vomitado lado pero yo lo intento
explicar que no era mi culpa que no no
soy yo no es nuestro propósito me
intoxiqué sin querer con el agua que
estaba lado mío
siguen pasando los días y empezar a
cuenta que ya estaba perdiendo las
fuerzas no sólo físicas pero mentalmente
también estaba debilitando me y también
no creo que estaba un día también uno de
estos días en el secuestro sentado
acostado ya perdiendo las fuerzas y dije
guau cuánto daría yo por estar ahorita y
me sale tele sentada viendo cualquier
cosa la tele contrario pues acaso en mi
cama algo tenía todos los días y nunca
me había dado cuenta como no apreciado
las cosas cotidianas hasta que llegaba a
estar en un extremo tan fuerte como uno
no valora lo que tiene día a día hasta
que tiene que ser una situación tan
extrema y lo que yo les digo tienen que
empezar
tienen que aprender y empezar a valorar
porque no todos nos va a pasar la
experiencia así pues y todos tenemos un
rato de comida al frente
siguieron pasando los días hasta que
ella se concluyó fueron 11 y me acuerdo
que cuando ya estábamos empezando a
subir la quebrada de regreso para que yo
me junte con familia mi mochila era tan
pesada por los pocos fuerzas que tenía
que lanzó mi mochila fue la quebrada me
preocupó mucho una vez más dos libros
y me dijo que me jalaba me dijo que me
apure que ya iba por fin volver
era lo único que quería tener un tiempo
mi cuerpo ya no daba yo no podía seguir
caminando porque no tenía las fuerzas
con muchas fuerzas tuve que seguir
subiendo el mayor a bomba como empujaba
hasta que logramos terminar de subir la
quebrada
llegamos otra vez una planicie y me
metió en un tubo grande de cemento me
amarró los pies las manos y me puso una
cinta la boca para custo dentro ese tubo
y me dijo que no me podía mover que iba
a regresar
se fue y no creo que lo primero es que
yo dije pues sé que quizás puede que
esta sea la última noche ya habían
pasado tantos días y yo ya estaba tan
débil que
que pese a perder un poco la esperanza y
ese día dije pues sé que hoy día sea la
última noche que me duerma y no me
vuelva a despertar y empecé a quedarme
dormida ni siquiera intentado escaparme
ni siquiera intentado salir ya ya no
tenía las fuerzas y una vez es que me
estaba quedando el me demás creo que
alguien llamó mi nombre y yo al
principio no conteste porque tenía amigo
que sea el si es que era él yo no quería
contestar yo no quería que me voy a
encontrar prefería quedarme ahí entonces
ya que veis mi nombre más de una vez
para reconocer la voz y darme cuenta que
no era el cáliz más recién ahí me saqué
la cinta la boca contesté me acuerdo que
llegó un señor que yo no sabía quién era
pero gritó aquí la tenemos y llegó
muchos más me cogieron no estuvieron un
auto yo estaba tan débil que no me
acuerdo ese trayecto en el auto no me
acuerdo haber estado ahí no quedó nada
la siguiente cena para mí es estar en un
cuarto acostada y todos se tomaban fotos
conmigo yo no entendía por qué de la
nada tanto formalmente un día porque era
la sensación así de la nada y me acuerdo
que me preguntó qué quería comer y yo
pedir por favor una sopita de pollo
porque sólo quería ese sentimiento de
hogar
y también estudié que por favor me
lleven a ver amistades porque lo único
que quería me volvían a subir un auto
firmado hasta quito donde se encontró a
mis papás una vez más no me acuerdo
satélite en el auto y llegamos me
llevaron a marca de encontrarme con mis
papás estaban en un cuarto estaba la
prensa estaba la policía me junté con
ellos y se dieron cuenta que sí o qué
increíble ya la tenemos se ha estado tan
débil ya metido en que iba de urgencia
al hospital me bajé estuve en hospital
varios días y mucha gente dice ya que
hay sangrado secuestro y no es nada si
no siempre las situaciones acaban en el
momento del rescate
y ahí empezó toda la segunda parte del
secuestro que fue superar
yo estaba mi cuerpo había entrado en un
estado tan de shock
no podía perder no quería estar alerta
como estuvo 11 días amarrado a un árbol
prácticamente yo siempre había estado
atenta puede venir un animal puede venir
a alguien en esta la atenta si es que
llueve y crece el río tope es mar y
drogada entonces mi cuerpo entra en este
estado
inconscientemente tanto sigue cuando
estaba en el hospital parecía estar
dormida pero me sepan 100 preguntas y yo
les contestaba y yo estaba dormida pero
mi cuerpo no lograba descansar al 100%
empiezo a tener horas de terapia para
curarme de mi estrés postraumático
fue tan así que un día cuando ya salí
del hospital está a costa de mi cama y
escuché un sonido de ruedas y salí
corriendo mi mamá y mi mamá le están
secuestrando a alguien y mejor no julia
a los vecinos se niegan al viaje pero
sonido para mí de las ruedas era el
basurero y yo estaba segura de que
estaban secuestrando alguien
y ahí fue cuando mi familia tomó un rol
muy importante y me hicieron tienes dos
opciones te pasó algo no fácil de
superar pero tienes dos opciones o te
vuelves la víctima o sigues adelante y
aprendes de esto
mi hermano tuvo un rol muy importante en
esto porque él era el que me hacía no
ser una víctima yo intentaba alguna vez
pobrecita yo hoy el mes que te pasa o
sea ya superarlo y yo bueno
y siguieron pasando los días tuve que
como les dije tener muchas horas de
terapia tuve que mejorar y mucha gente
también me dijo en esta recuperación
deja hablar ese secuestro porque
nosotros olvida si sigues adelante pero
quieres intentar estirar es no entienden
cuando alguien le pasa una experiencia
si se le navidad a todos nos ha pasado
no es que pasó y ahí se acaba cuando uno
crece pues si regresan a ver una
historia así como para mí es de esta y
yo la veo con unos ojos diferentes la
veo con una perspectiva más madura y
cada vez que ve esta historia aprenda
algo nuevo
aprendo algo que no me había dado cuenta
antes
y hace pocos años le dije que habla con
ustedes porque quiere al acabarse quiero
decirles que les perdonan los
secuestradores quiero decirles
personalmente mira te perdona y te
perdono no porque te justifica lo que
hiciste porque no está bien pero te
perdono por dos razones primero tengo la
mentalidad de que cada uno reacciona
acorde a su realidad y que tal vez ésta
no fue la situación y nos cometió no
justifica el hecho pero quién sabe en mi
caso por quién sabe que en ese momento
para él tenía una hija en el hospital y
su única manera sin dinero era esa era
su única solución para salvarle la vida
a su hija
cada uno actúa acorde su realidad y yo
tenía que ser lo mismo y mi realidad de
la serie adelante la segunda es a lyon
no perdona les ellos siguen teniendo un
vínculo muy importante conmigo y en mi
vida y al yo decirse es que te perdono
esto que tú tienes conmigo se corta yo
sigo adelante ya no me importaba si es
que ellos estaban bien y yo estaba mal
pero este poder que siguen teniendo
sobre mí para
y sigo viendo esta historia cada vez me
dice que la voy a seguir revisando a ver
porque me ha hecho quién soy yo ahora y
me ha
creado y mucha gente no me hace quién
soy yo ahora es mi historia es mi vida y
no sé quién sería yo sin esta historia
sin esta experiencia porque es lo que
aprendí
y que así les que aprendan y tienen que
valorar la vida cotidiana tiene que
aprender ha sido adelante como les digo
uno no tiene uno no tiene uno no decide
lo que le pasa pero si decide cómo
reacciona a lo que le pasa y tal vez
para mí fue un bosque tal vez para mí el
miedo era la oscuridad que me rodeaba en
esos 11 días pero cada uno tiene su
seguridad cada uno tiene su bosque
y es tu deber dominarlo en vez de que
eso les domine ustedes
[Aplausos]